well we're a Steve Sanger who is the st.
Louis County Executive welcome to the
show now you've been the county
executive since 2015 I believe it is
what has been the challenge of being the
Big Dawg well there are many challenges
many opportunities but you know really
bringing everyone together is I think
the greatest opportunity that we've had
is bringing everyone together and moving
upward together you know economically
and you know in every aspect well you're
here at the world-famous st. Louis Chess
Club what has been the partnership with
the club in bringing international
tournament so let me actually ask first
about the economic impact of having
these kind of sterling tournaments going
on here in st. Louis it's really
incredible we estimate that this
tournament has about well in excess of a
million dollars of economic impact for
them for the region which is incredible
that's pretty cool in count am i sharing
in some of that that happened come on
all right I won't get you in any trouble
what about chess you know in we have a
lot of chests going on with the kids in
the city is expanding to the counties
how is that partnership benefiting you
it really teaches some valuable skills
for our youth you know when you talk
about just the analytical side of chess
the planning ahead and the discipline
that it requires not to mention just the
intellectual engagement I think it's
really uh it's just a great thing for
kids to take part in you see it
expanding oh I did sure absolutely you
know and you know just the other evening
I was talking with my staff and I was
meeting with with some chess folks and
we were talking about ways that we could
bring chess even more into the county so
awesome we're working on those things
right now are you a trance player you
know you could say I am sort of sort of
a chess game I try to stay about five
moves ahead and you know so in that
respect yes it's dangerous calling
yourself a chess player in this place
you'll be challenged instantly
fifteen people really I want to beat
that guy and I I was reading here it was
intriguing me while I was waiting for
Jay to throw it to me that you will
share something in common with the
founder Rex Sinquefield and also Jack
Dorsey the founder of Twitter sure what
do you know what that is I'll bet I know
it's bishop to Berg we went to high
school in the same place pretty amazing
that the high school is producing such
sterling people in the world well you
know I'm not at the caliber of those
individuals but I will tell you that
it's a it was a great school great
education
we had a Chess Club you did we did did
you we did I did not play but we did
have one okay well those guys are
special today's I know I know Rex played
on the chest well thank you so much
thank you for coming and thanks for
having me I really appreciate with all
the work you're doing the great work
you're doing oh well thank you I
appreciate that thank you